you
[Music]
let me dive right in and say first of
all Netflix isn't a single product it
really is hundreds of millions of
products because each user or member or
profile gets their own Netflix
experience that's tailored and shape to
them in order to optimize their
engagement there are a retention at the
end of the month so that they want to
renew and so if you look at any one
person's Netflix homepage you won't look
like your Netflix on page and that's
because we're really trying to
personalize with machine learning every
aspect of it in order to get folks to
continue to stream and watch and be
engaged and then to renew at the end of
the month and so if you look at what's
happening out of the thousands of
thousands of movies and TV shows we have
to figure out for you what are the top
20-30 TV shows and movies that really
you'd be interested in so we have to
rank everything and say here the top
let's say a few dozen that really are
the ones you're gonna be interested in
watching we personalize the page layout
so where do you want to put those top
titles for you do you want to kind of
organize them into rows with different
let's say groupings do you want to have
them kind of scattered about we also
think that do things like personalize
the promotion of new stuff that's just
launched so what should we show you that
just got added to the service as a
billboard or a trailer way up top on on
the top of your page and today I'll be
talking a lot about personalized image
selection and artwork selection but
there's also machine learning in things
like our search engine how we message
people because we want to tell them
about shows that just got released we
could send you a text or a push
notification or an email saying hey
check out this new show for you we think
you'd be really interested in it because
you watch something else and I'll keep
going into some of these other examples
but first let me just remind folks one
of the first things that Netflix really
pioneered in 2006 was this thing called
a Netflix challenge and that was really
looking at how do we do collaborative
ranking so that we can all help each
other figure out what are the top movies
that we should be paying attention to
out of thousands or tens of thousands of
options so if you look back twelve years
ago now there was this really
interesting data set that came out of
Netflix which was a big matrix of many
many movies
and many many users and then the star
ratings of those movies for those and
for those users and so that one user
might have watched let's say stranger
things and Zootopia and so she's given
two stars and three stars so you've got
this matrix which is actually much
bigger than 3x3 and the challenge was to
guess the stars for some hidden entries
in this matrix we've moved away from
stars because it turns out what really
matters is the place people really are
engaging in and not so much the star
rating and because stars are very
aspirational people tend to give you
know five stars - let's say movies like
Citizen Kane because it's historic and
well-known but no one really wants to
watch Citizen Kane so it doesn't get
that many plays but it gets a lot of
five stars so it turns out just looking
at what people play is a lot more
informative and you can imagine for
every user you can have this long binary
vector which we call kind of their play
history which is out of all the movies
put a one on the movies and TV shows
they watch and put a zero on the ones
they haven't and that represents that
users let's say view history so the
classic approach in 2006 which really
popped up and was really very relevant
for this challenge was this thing called
linear matrix factorization so you take
that ratings matrix R and you figure out
how to rewrite it as a product of two
skinny matrices U and M so you know U
and M might be kind of four by a million
and M might be you know four by a
hundred thousand you take the product to
those two things and you make this giant
matrix which is a million by a hundred
thousand so if you figure out how to
rewrite our approximately as u times M
that gives you an idea of how to fill in
the missing entries of R so we moved
away from linear factorization because
it turns out you want nonlinear let's
say machine learning power to really
help drive improvements here and you can
imagine having the view history being
reconstructed through a neural network
so rather than reconstruct your view
history is a product of two skinny
matrices you can say let me think of a
neural network which takes my view
History X on the left hand side
then multiplies it by some matrix
squashes it through some sigmoids
multiplies by another matrix squashes it
down and you keep going through these
nonlinearities and then you get the
smaller version of you're feeling
history called Z which is kind of the
code and that's kind of like one of the
pieces of that skinny matrix like
instead of having a four by a million
skinny matrix here you can have like a
four dimensional code it's a little more
than four but you get the idea and then
you can grow that code back into an
approximate view history and that
approximate view history is gonna have
some values in your past zeroes which
are nonzero and those tell you what are
the movies you'd be likely to be
interested in next okay so the zeroes
will kind of grow into nonzero values
and the bigger they get the more
important that is for your next movie
recommendation so you can reconstruct
the x as closely as possible but you
have to shrink it down to a lower
dimensionality just like the skinny
matrices shrank down to lower
dimensionality but now we have
nonlinearities you can have many of
these kind of slow dimensional
reductions you can also instead of
trying to reconstruct the users view
history perfectly say put a distribution
like a Gaussian distribution around the
view history and say okay it's roughly
around here and with this kind of
uncertainty you know so a Gaussian bell
curve with error bars turns out that's a
little bit better because you know your
view history is kind of a reconstruction
it's kind of our best guess of where
you're gonna go in the future given what
you've watched in the past but there's
uncertainty around where you're gonna go
in future so you really should put a
full Gaussian distribution to capture
that uncertainty this was a technique
that was called a variational auto
encoder it was proposed by max Kingma at
Maxwell and Deidre Kingma in 2014 and it
does strictly better than regular auto
encoders and kind of traditional neural
networks and we further improved beyond
that by saying let's go away from the
Gaussian uncertainty and let's put a
multinomial uncertainty because the
Gaussian doesn't really make sense if
you think about it Gaussian ZUP
probabilities that go negative it's
impossible to have kind of a negative
movie preference and so
we replace the Gaussian at the very end
with a multinomial distribution and that
was published a few months ago with some
of my collaborators and that nicely
gives you better predictions that also
turned out to some to one across the
entire catalog so then you get kind of a
distribution of what's the probably
gonna play this next that next and the
whole thing has to sum to one
because you can't have more than 100
percent probability across all the
movies just a quick highlight of some of
the results if you try this on
standardized data sets it does a lot
better so here's the million movie lines
20 million data set and the Netflix data
set and it turns out this multi nale
multinomial variational auto encoder is
beating kind of the non let's say
multinomial one and it's beating the the
classical auto encoder and it's beating
weighted matrix factorization which is
that classical technique I showed you
from 12 years ago and so those are the
linear techniques so we're moving into a
nonlinear world and a probabilistic
nonlinear world that's kind of the
better way to capture how to do ranking
ok so then here's another quick vignette
before we jump into the artwork
personalization so one issue is as we
were learning off of and of what people
have watched in order to do better
recommendation we also discover some
interesting extensions into causal
machine learning and that's because most
of machine learning out there is what I
just showed you kind of predict what the
person is gonna do next but the reality
is when you intervene things kind of get
really strange and here's an example
I'll talk about in a second but it turns
out for most machine learning we don't
learn just to learn or just to make a
prediction we learn in order to make an
action in the real world we learn models
that tell us what to do next the
problems when we act on those models you
change the source of the data that was
used to collect initially the data to
train your models and so it turns out
you actually have to start thinking
about things like causality this is how
big us motivate kind of the next
stage but here's a really interesting
toy problem just to get us to think
about causality this is the price of
airline tickets over time and for let's
say one one airline and the number of
flights being reserved over time and so
you can see these kind of spikes in
demand at let's say the holidays in 2015
the holidays in 2016 the holidays in
2017 and you can see the prices as well
going up during those times right
everyone knows that traveling for the
holidays is you know when everyone wants
to see family and prices are usually a
little steeper than when you go during a
quiet period so if you plotted the price
and the demand or the number of tickets
being sold as you know a little two by
two to divide sorry a little kind of
correlation plot like this you'd see
there's a strong correlation with number
of flights being sold and the price
going up right so you can't use this
machine learning model now that was
trained on the past data and say oh
great if I increase price demand goes up
and people buy more of my tickets right
even though that's what the data is
telling you we know that's not how the
world works and this correlation does
not imply causation so this is one of
these aha things that you quickly
realize when you start dealing with
machine learning for the real world and
the reason is because there's something
called a hidden confounder it's not that
price alone is determining the demand
there's another hidden confounder C
which is for example holidays or there's
a conference in town everybody wants to
travel to that conference or a couple of
coure located conferences and so most of
machine learning is trying to learn kind
of an input to output behavior X is an
input and Y is some target output we
learned these great functions that go
from X to Y called f of X the problem
with that is we assume when you learn f
of X equals y you assume that X
completely controls
y
there's nothing else that's affecting
this kind of world you're studying right
it's not just that price is what
determines demand there's another hidden
variable C which actually determines
both C determines kind of your appetite
for paying more because if it's the
holidays you really have to see family
you will travel no matter what and so it
can actually change your price
sensitivity
it'll also increase demand because more
people have that time often need to
travel in so C is actually hitting
confounder which is messing up the
analysis and if you're not careful you
will learn if you just do traditional
machine learning silly relationships and
correlations in the data that cannot be
acted upon you know if you see people
walking in the street with umbrellas
when a training and machine learning
model might say oh you want it to stop
raining tell everyone to keep their
umbrella at home and so turns out we
discover this the hard way when we said
let's look at how we do personalized
mesh messaging and send kind of emails
or push notifications or pop-up
notifications to our members we
basically studied it say how X let's say
the messaging number of messages when
and what types of messages effect the
watching of a member so if you watch if
you watch more after messages are sent
to you that means we should send you
more messages right it seems to be
driving your viewing but it turns out
the same issue kind of affected us and
when we just learned kind of the
relationship between messaging and how
much people watched that f of X equals y
relationship was kind of silly and it's
because there's hidden confounders and
the main hidden confounders people watch
more netflix when they also open up
their emails about netflix and check
their pop-up notifications and it's just
because people are busy from 9:00 to
5:00 working then they're done with work
that's when they check kind of their
pop-up notifications and their emails
from us and that also happens to be when
they're also available and able to watch
and you know get a TV show or movie in
and so this correlation where the hidden
confounder is really what's messing up
that relationship and we studied
let's relationship from between x and y
and realize it wasn't really capturing
what we wanted and that's because there
was a hidden confounder which is you
know the time of day and other things we
can't really measure so the way we fix
this is we said let's add some little
randomization Z this little source of
randomizations basically think of it as
a coin flip which says every now and
then you were gonna send a message don't
send it or you were gonna send one
message send it or you know coin flip
you were gonna send a message actually
send two messages so something that
randomizes how you do your messaging and
that breaks the correlation right and so
then we do this two-stage learning we
learn a function which says from this Z
randomization predict X which is the
messaging and then using the
reconstructed X learn another function G
to predict Y and it turns out now if you
do this two stages of learning you first
learn F then you learn G that G will
actually capture the true causal
relationships because of these hidden
confounders and so turns out this was an
idea that goes way back it was used to
help prove that cigarettes cause cancer
and not that cancer causes more smoking
of cigarettes or predisposition to
cancer and z was that this taxes that
were applied on on cigarette sales by
different states that was kind of a
pseudo random thing happening some
states were taxing cigarettes some
states weren't that sort of
randomization then gets you the actual
causal relationship so long story short
here's an example where we actually
studied how much email push or in app
notifications helped you watch more on
top is if you just learned using
ordinary kind of least squares a model
that predicts watching minutes from at a
number of emails pushes and enough
notifications and that model told us
really strange stuff when we didn't do
this kind of causal version it told us
if you send emails you actually decrease
viewing by a little bit
if you send push notifications you
decrease viewing by a lot and if you
send in up notifications you increase
viewing by a good amount and that's
because it was not the causal model it
was just learning f of X equals y and
you know of course your business
partners who are actually going to look
at this say this is completely nonsense
how can sending someone a push
notification make them watch a whole lot
less but it turns out if you do the
two-stage version then you get the
correct coefficients and you figure out
then okay emails help people watch a
little bit push notifications get a huge
increase in viewing and then in app
notifications get a tiny blip upwards in
doing but you don't get this nonsensical
decrease in viewing when you message
someone which you would have learned if
you don't understand causality which is
what 99% of machine learning out there
does it's non-causal machine learning
just correlational even if you have a
deep neural network it's really chasing
after your correlations rather than
causations okay so let me now talk about
the image personalization effort and we
talked about kind of how to personalize
and rank and then how to be kind of
mindful of causality when you intervene
and then another one is you have to
actually explain why you're intervening
to the users why are you showing me this
machine learnings great at making
predictions you can be more causal with
your predictions but the user still
needs to understand why this is kind of
what the machine learning system wants
you to do so this is what the homepage
looked like before we started
personalizing images it just doesn't the
algorithms don't care how you're gonna
present these different movies it just
says Oh put stranger things in the top
right billboard and put bright in the
second position of the first row and
then etc etc but it doesn't really know
how these movies and TV shows are gonna
be portrayed and so the question is
which artwork should we show for
different movies and using machine
learning it was kind of interesting to
say let's change the answer for every
single user maybe some users really
liked that top left picture because it's
got this kind of spookiness
and in a scary forest looking thing and
it tells you oh there's some some kind
of scariest aspect maybe some other
users will like that middle picture in
the bottom because it shows you know
there's some kind of perhaps a
relationship going on with two
characters and they're kind of teenagers
high school kids and that's interesting
for some users who really want a story
about someone they can relate to and so
we thought let's use machine learning to
personalize that decision and at first
we tried to take the classical approach
again standard batch machine learning
correlational machine learning where we
collect a bunch of data and then out of
all the possible models in kind of our
machine learning library try to find the
one that fits the data the best this is
kind of the classical machine learning
point of view right you sit back you
collect months and months within months
of worth of data then you have a giant
grab bag of models and different
parameters for those models and you say
this is the one light bulb model that
fits at best and you try to do this
efficiently with computational speed and
statistical guarantees but that's the
basic machine learning approach called
batch machine learning turns out there's
a very big cost of that approach when
you're dealing with kind of real systems
in the real world and that is we've got
this long process that we're kind of
spending months over our massive user
database of hundreds of millions of
different people where we have to
collect data on those people then spend
some time learning that model then
tuning it engineering it then running
this big thing called an a/b test where
in experience a half the users get the
classical machine learned sorry
classical Netflix experience and in a
and B and R the other half of the users
get this new machine learning spear
Ian's and then we see which one kind of
does better is it a or B and if B is
better than we roll out B to everyone
else a problem with that is it incurs
this massive amount of regret because
for many many months you're wasting time
collecting tons of data and building
these models that they're just just
perfect and then you're saying now let's
test they're just perfect model Intel
and Selby
for several months compare it to sell a
and then finally you're like oh this is
better and so for all these users and
all these months you've been giving them
really a worse experience until you roll
it out that's the classical approach and
we said let's be a little more mindful
about this big waste of resource and
look at online learning which is a much
more efficient way of minimizing that
regret and so the idea there is lets
interleave the learning machine learning
process with the data collection process
let's interleave kind of learning and
action taking with data collection
rather than waiting for all the data to
be there then waiting for the best best
model to be figured out and then take
action interleave the learning the
action and the data collection together
that's called online learning and the
classical approach to this is related to
this multi armed bandits technique where
you think of you walk into a casino
there's many slot machines each one of
them pays off with a different
probability and you can play one arm at
a time as a gambler you want to figure
out which arm or omission machine is the
is the best paying one and so you want
to try them out and you're collecting
data about the machines but you don't
want to sit there on one machine and
just try it a thousand times so you're
exactly sure that it's not a very good
payoff machine and then move on to the
next you want to kind of try the
machines and then kind of slowly figure
out oh this is the lucky one that really
pays out a lot and just keep going to it
afterwards and so there's smart
algorithms that figure out how to do
this optimally and you can apply those
and the basic idea behind a multi-armed
bandit is you've got some learner and
the environment and you really want to
sequence the learning with the action
and the rewarding you're gonna get right
not just wait for tons of learning
before you figure out how to take
optimal actions so the learner chooses
an action tries it in the environment
observes a reward updates kind of their
model and then chooses a better action
and it really is trying to maximize
cumulative reward or minimize kind of
cumulative or minimize cumulative regret
in hindsight both of those are
equivalent and so that's kind of the
idea versus just collect tons of data
and along the way maybe have very few
rewards until you're super confident
then be super rewarded you try to blend
it too and then there's a version called
a contextual bandit where in addition
the environment also tells you a context
so you get information like is the is it
is this slot machine blinking or is a is
the slot machine you know a loud big
slot machine or a small slot machine of
the corner so there's additional
information about the slot machines
called context but similarly it's the
same idea
it's the algorithms are very similar but
the key difference between standard
supervised learning and bandits is again
this idea of online learning and taking
action and updating your models in a
kind of sequential way but in a bandit
unlike supervised learning where you get
input X you predict an output Y and then
you get to see what's Y correct yes or
no and you get to see the real Y the
actual label afterwards right and
supervised learning we get to see the
target in contextual bandits you see an
input X you predict an action to take a
and the world only tells you if a was
good or bad it gives you a dollar if you
got the right answer gives you zero
dollars if you didn't but doesn't tell
you oh the best action was action 15
when you proposed action 12 that was
wrong
should have said action 15 it just tells
you no action 12 was wrong I won't tell
you what the right one ought was that's
kind of another fundamental aspect of
contextual bandits that's different from
classical machine learning of X to Y so
in other words here's an example of how
supervised learning if you say here's a
picture that's the context and you say
ok I'm gonna label this as a cat you're
told that's wrong and the correct label
is dog right that's the supervised
approach in contextual bandit you say
that's a cat you're told no that's wrong
you have to try again because you can't
just say oh now I know the labels dog
like it was done in the second example
here now you have to try again you can't
say Fox and
that's not Fox also you get zero reward
try seal so it takes a lot more effort
when you only get this kind of you know
reward type signal versus the true label
so here's sorry I didn't do the
drop-down um so again there's a cat you
guess dog it's wrong eventually for the
next example you know to see dog
immediately but in the contextual bandit
example you have to keep trying until
you get the the correct answer so it may
take you 12 tries on the same input to
figure out what the right output is
because you're only getting binary
answers okay so for the artwork problem
this is how we set it up as a contextual
bandit the context X is that user's view
history what did they like to watch in
the past what country are they in things
like that the action is what's the best
image to show for that show so that TV
show or that movie so there may be in
this example nine different images for
stranger things sometimes you know 20 or
so images you show that image for
stranger things for that user that's the
action you took all you get to see is
the user didn't like it and didn't play
the user doesn't tell you oh by the way
if you show me the image of those two
kind of teenagers then I would have
played it then I'll tell you the actual
true label they just tell you no that
was bad so you have to try something
else and then you get the binary reward
Niva uh-huh that's that's the image that
work for them so you may have to do kind
of nine different tribes until you get
that reward figure it out okay so what
is a good outcome for us the reward is
when our subscribers at home want some
content like it enjoy it okay that's the
reward for for our algorithms a bad
outcome is they don't click they don't
watch they abandon that session they try
to find something and then they just do
something else instead and we're gonna
read a book or play game
all right so that's our reward reward is
people watching and you can compute how
well you're doing roughly by this thing
called the take rate so if you look at
we have let's say three users and this
is what we show them on their page that
there's a female user up top she gets
all these images on her home page then
there's another couple of users they get
these other images and we're trying to
figure out for altered carbon how good
is this image of altered carbon see that
top left image it's kind of someone's
neck and there's kind of a glowy thing
on the back of their neck so it turns
out for that female user she liked that
image and she clicked and watched those
two other users got to serve that same
image they didn't click and watch so we
got rewarded once out of three attempts
and so we get a take rate of one third
for altered carbon ok so we think of it
as we made one dollar out of three
possible max dollars we could have made
in that situation that's the take rate
so how do we optimize take rate and
minimize regret maximizing maximize
cumulative reward we do this thing
called a contextual bandit and the
actual specific algorithm there's a
bunch out there there's UCB there's
epsilon greedy there's Thompson sampling
Thompson sampling is a pretty good one
at it handles kind of non-stationarity
in the data so users can kind of change
their mind and things can kind of evolve
over time but the basic big picture is
instead of looking at all your users and
waiting until you have that single best
model with Thompson sampling try a bunch
of models randomly different users get
different models and then you slowly
eliminate models that seem to be working
badly and you drop them out you X them
out then you keep trying and trying and
trying and eventually you'll kill off
all the bad models until you're left
with that best light bulb model that's
kind of the idea behind Thompson
sampling you start off with a prior
distribution which is all models are all
pretty much equally good that's kind of
the P of theta the models and then you
sample from that and then you do with
that model some action you get an a
context X
you compute an action get a reward and
then you update your data and you update
your models distribution and now you've
eliminated some models and favored
others and slowly you'll figure out what
the winner is but unlike the old
approach where you have to do tons of
data collection tons of modeling and
then try things out here you're doing
kind of slow elimination of the bad
models so here's an example of how we
figure out what the best image without
any contacts this is just an unperson
alized solution and a non contextual
bandit this is just a vanilla bandit
where we don't care about the context of
what does this user watch and what
country they in we quickly figure out by
doing kind of this thompson sampling
algorithm that the bottom right image is
the best one and that's the one that
gets the most rewards and we try all six
randomly eventually just like being in a
casino with six slot machines we figure
out that's the best long machine where
there was two actors in it but then we
can also include the context which is
the users view history and say okay
what's the best lot machine for you
what's the best image for you based off
of your view history in the country
you're in and a few other things but
primarily that no other kind of
demographic information for example if
you watch a lot of romance like this
person here with serendipity eternal
sunshine and while you were sleeping the
best image for Good Will Hunting is this
one that's what the algorithm figures
out because you like you know that's the
gateway into this movie why should I pay
attention to this movie we figure out
you like romance and here's a romantic
thing that happens in this movie and
that's kind of motivation to give it a
try here's another user downstairs
that's the user who watches a lot of
silly comedies turns out if you watch a
lot of comedies the algorithm suggests
you should watch Good Will Hunting with
a picture of Robin Williams because he's
a comedian okay so it does kind of
sensible things you know a few other
things that realizes if you watch a lot
of mooma Thurman movies for a pulp
fiction show the picture with uma in it
if you watch a lot of John Travolta
movies for pulp fiction show the picture
of George
volta so this is kind of automatically
inferred from the data without you know
anyone saying oh this is how we
deterministic we figure out this rule
it's learned okay so how do we evaluate
how well this is doing it turns out
there's a great technique called replay
and this allows us to figure out if you
built an algorithm like this figure out
how well it will do once you've roll it
out in the real world so before you try
it out in the real world you have to
prove to the business folks that this is
gonna help but not hurt so here's an
example where for disenchantment we
change the image and we have six users
and half of them got the image with kind
of this queen princess with a crown and
then the other ones have this kind of
multi character image and these were
kind of random randomly assigned at the
very beginning those are the log actions
that happen in the real world we want to
predict now how a new algorithm which
will do different things does so here's
a new algorithm and it says for this
first user I should have shown them the
the queen picture for the second user
queen and the other two kind of the
multi character and then the last user
should have gone queen and queen how
good is this algorithm given the data
we've logged in the past and we don't
have the counterfactual right I don't
have for example for this that second
female user her response to that Queen
image I don't know what she would have
done maybe she would have played it when
she didn't play it before the way we do
it is we say okay look at when you
actually matched what happened in real
life and on those examples compute your
average take rate or your average reward
so forget the data when you don't match
but when you do match what happen in the
real kind of real world log data we
realize oh okay I matched half the time
with this new algorithm and this
algorithm picked correct matches where
there were two plays and picked a
correct match where there wasn't a place
so the take rate for this
would be 2/3 whereas for instance the
other random policy might have had to
take rate of 1/3 because only these two
things got plays for example right so
they the logging policy really got six
chances and got it right two out of six
but this new policy from our model only
agreed with a logged one half the time
but when it did agree it was on those
winners that actually got plays so
that's how we compute the this replay
take fraction it turns out this is this
is an unbiased way to evaluate how
you're doing before you go out in the
real world and try things out it's easy
to compute the observed awards are real
unfortunately it requires lots of data
and it has kind of high variance if
people kind of know what I mean there
are techniques to improve on it there's
a technique called doubly robust offline
policy evaluation as opposed to replay
but nevertheless it gives you a good
idea of before you go out and try stuff
out in the real world how well is it
gonna do so this is kind of our estimate
and take fraction of this contextual
bandit algorithm and you can see the
take fraction of random in green which
we just don't know anything we just try
images randomly on the user's that gives
us a pretty bad take fraction in the
middle is a bandit which doesn't care
about your view history it just figures
out what the best image is overall
doesn't try to personalize it just says
this is the best image if I had to throw
away all the other images and then the
contextual bandit is the one that
figures out for your use use for your
view history here's your best image for
your view history here's your best image
for your review history here's your best
image and it does definitely better than
non-personalized
and the variety also helps because if
you don't have too much variety there's
no point in personalizing if there's
just one image that's the winner no
matter what so there's about a dozen
sometimes more than that 20 or so images
if you kind of check with your friends
and their Netflix you'll say oh okay
there may be 12 different images for
orange the new black and
getting this one my friends are getting
that one and it sometimes Wiggles around
and changes the best image for you it's
not always the best image because your
view history changes your ex changes
over time you know you start watching
more romance you're gonna get the more
romantic images okay so how do we do
this now with an online performance
evaluation first if you want to go
online you need to be smart about your
engineering you need to scale a lot of
the stuff offline can be done with kind
of simpler approaches where you don't to
worry about you know latency and things
like this but when you're actually gonna
serve these images you're gonna add
calls from the Netflix UI for you know
what should I put on the home page what
image should I put in the search in the
galleries all these requests mean about
20 million requests per second at peak
so if you want to test this thing in the
real world it better be able to scale to
that number of requests and also the UI
code written is assuming image lookup is
super fast so it turns out if you want
to plug-in in a machine learning model
into this kind of super fast process it
might slow things down it might not be
reliable because you know we need really
need to test this out without really
rewriting the UI code or slowing you
down the UI code so there's two
strategies you could try live compute
where you compute the best image for
each user live or you can do online pre
compute where you pre compute for every
user not waiting for the request but pre
compute before they even open their
browser what the best images are for
each title for them this requires more
computation on the right and more
caching on the right hand side on the
left hand side it gives you the freshest
possible data because you only figure
out for this person what their image is
right now which means if they just want
to show you can maybe figure out oh they
just watched romantic show here's the
more romantic image this is super fresh
on the left hand side but it really
requires strict SLA and it's very fast
turnaround and me it makes you really
use only simple algorithms whereas if
you do online pre compute you can run
more complicated machine learning models
the problem is you have to compute for
every user ahead of time they're in
and store them and cash them so it's
making you kind of do more computation
and sometimes you don't need that actual
users image because they're not gonna
log in that day real quick here is the
architecture but the basic summary is
where you need to do this it pre-compute
and so for we run the bandit for each
title in each profile we choose the best
personalized image for that pair we
store that best personalized image pair
for that user in evey cache and then we
can do a quick lookup off of EB cache at
request time so again we're not doing
live computation of the images at
request that's the key we also have to
do a lot of logging ahead of time we in
precompute we log what the image was
that was selected for this particular
user and movie pair we we store the
probability of that image being selected
remember these are bandits if the log
the probabilities event having taken
that action with the log of the
candidate pool because in some countries
some images aren't available for various
reasons legal and so on and we also
snapshot your features the context of
the user at that time so all that has to
happen as well there's a lot of logging
happening behind the hood and then we
have to join the rewards with the
features and this is done all kind of
with delorean we train the model using
spark and this is gets then published to
production and at the end we have now a
scalable system we also have to monitor
it we track the quality of the model
online all the time making sure none of
these jobs are failing we compare a kind
of offline metrics to online metrics and
we keep a little bit of the traffic also
with randomized images just to do sanity
checks and then finally we also have a
graceful degradation scheme so it's
great to do super sophisticated machine
learning and personalized images but
sometimes more complicated systems fail
more often so it's good to have a
simpler backup system for when the
complicated thing fails and then even so
you find the best image in a nun
personalized way and show that if you
don't have the best personalized winner
and go to a default it may
if you really don't know what to show
because both systems failed so we have
kind of a hierarchy of machine learning
systems that are simpler and simpler and
simpler in case the complicated ones
fail there's always some backup image
users don't like it when you show a
black icon for for a movie with a number
on it okay so we tested this as an a/b
test it worked and improved let's say
the engagement of the users and was
rolled out to 130 million members and it
turns out to help the most for
lesser-known titles everyone knows pulp
fiction's so you don't really need to
know although John Travolta's and pulp
fiction now I'll watch it but something
new that's not well-known it's important
to kind of figure out for that new title
what is the connection with this user so
that they'll actually give it a charge a
try
like the why behind the machine learning
oh you're recommending me this title why
oh because it has a cool car chase scene
and that's what the picture is telling
me and I like action and car chases
here's a video
[Music]
[Music]
okay so very quick what's next I mean if
it works well on images which you try to
change every aspect of the UI and make
it all personalized so we're looking at
ways of changing how we present the rows
the rankings that the title of the row
the evidence like oh this won an Emmy or
not should we personalize what we tell
you about it the synopsis should I write
long text or you only want short text
versus just changing the images the
metadata you know all of that can also
be personalized the trailer choice can
also be personalized and finally we're
also looking at ways of picking the
artwork automatically rather than having
people doing kind of a curated artwork
kind of palette and giving us the 20
images for a show can we just kind of
scan the footage of the show and
automatically find potential good
artwork and then do this kind of
personalization edge it on top of that
so great I'll wrap up here we're hiring
if you are interested take a look at
research Netflix com thank you very much
and one of your earlier slides you
mentioned multi multi noisy can you talk
a bit about what how you detect noise is
what you do to discard them and does
that help or improve your selections so
the denoising good question it's so we
were saying multi normal you know and
saying we're not actually denoising it
in the classical way we're just saying
that that's our model of the noise and
the uncertainty and it basically changes
your neural nets loss function and it
also gives you an output which is really
a kind of a sum to one probability so
that's all we really did we changed the
last layer of a neural net so it gives
you a slightly different output than
what a typical neural net gives you
which is just a bunch of numbers between
you know minus infinity and plus
infinity now gives out a distribution
which sums to one across the entire
catalog of movies and TV shows
so if a user starts watching a movie and
then stops watching it because they
didn't like it so what is the what about
the algorithm do about this because if
you give it like an image day like
you're gonna start and then regret
having started it so you would learn if
you want them if you say oh it's bad if
they do that then you give them the
worst possible image so they don't even
start right so that's a good point um we
do have better ways of evaluating if
somebody really got their value from
starting that movie and TV show so if
you start a TV show and you only watch
you know for a few seconds and cancel we
don't count that as a reward so the
reward is actually a little more subtle
than just clicking it's not click based
reward it's really looking at how much
you watch as well but that's kind of
really in the weeds and the details yeah
it's a good point yeah you want enough
of this show of being watched for it to
be considered a reward think of it that
way and how do you address the issues
that there are multiple users under the
same accounts so for example if Emily or
so for multiple users on the same
account sometimes you can switch
profiles and that tells you if you're in
with in one profile you're watching
romance in another profile you're
watching cartoons then we personalize
for the profile but if it's many people
sharing a profile then we just treat it
as a user who has a you know a diverse
viewing we don't try to tease apart who
is really behind the screen so when
doing playback to evaluate your newly
learned policy how why doesn't the take
rate of the the old take rate the old
success rate of the images that you've
now changed matter so the old take away
does matter so if the old locking policy
had a really bad take rate then it's
harder to get a really great taker
because you have to only agree with it
when it was successful so yeah you you
basically have this high variance
problem where you want to improve as
high as possible your take rate but you
also want to coincide very often with
the old logging policy
and so there's kind of a trade-off there
yeah well are you liberating you know
one more question yeah sorry yeah are
you liberating any of the recommendation
systems that are out there because you
know I know you're talking about
contextual algorithms right there are
recommendation systems like prediction
IO action ml is it home built within
Netflix or you know are using something
that's out there liberating I mean so in
terms of all the code behind all these
algorithms it's all custom written code
we're not kind of using standard
packages a lot of the stuff the you know
the equations are fairly reasonable but
the implementation because of the scale
we really have to do with our own
in-house custom frameworks so the kind
of context you abandoned is kind of like
proprietary so that the code for all
this is built in-house proprietary yeah
[Music]